[Applause]
[Music]
it's a piece that would be ball weaving
clunkiness for about five years
to
they
[Music]
that second
don't go with it please don't go look at
it
[Applause]
can everyone hear me great so let me
this first start by thanking Jared I
mean he's doing just such an incredible
job with this Meetup and you know I've
always really valued this community I
know I've learned a lot from it and you
know he's he's an integral part of that
and also yards team everyone is helping
out so thank you guys so much also thank
you all for coming out and take care of
there you're harder in time to spend
some time talking about this topic so
does Jared mentioned I talked about
reinforcement learning I think three
years ago now and I thought it was time
for an update you know it's funny
there's a video of me get in that talk
on YouTube and I know I noticed you know
occasionally I go in to check you know
how many passes so you'd and so forth
and I noticed in one of the comments
that someone said god what an idiot you
know he said they're never gonna stall
go and then you know you're later I made
lists to say go Vassallo
now in my defense I definitely didn't
say that but but any cuz I want to
correct the record you know go has been
kind of solved and I'll explain what
that means but I also want to go through
some examples of things that have
happened since that time so the talk is
called the 10,000 hour rule
it's kind of a play on Malcolm Gladwell
Gladwell's book the basic point is that
with reinforcement learning kinds of
problems and a lot of these interactive
problems we're basically just spending
lots of time trying to do that it's a
very kind of silly ways or idiotic ways
and over many many interactions we're
gonna learn to become pretty smart so I
just wanted to start off with this quote
from Elon Musk I'm sure many of you I've
seen some of these things so he's been
at the forefront of kind of being
concerned about AI and you know I find
it kind of interesting because what I'm
gonna spend a lot of time talking today
about is an organization called open AI
and Yan is one of the primary founders
or
funders for that organization and yet
he's also really worried about AI as a
problem so if you if you look actually
at what opening eye is trying to do one
of its main objectives is called safety
and basically what they're trying to do
is find ways to build AI so everyone has
access to it there are no single
individuals in the world for instance
who have access to this which might be
considered kind of like a weapon of mass
mass destruction and they also want to
build AI in a way that it's safe so it
can't cut unleash on the world and do
terrible things so just keep that in
mind as we go this is the outline and
I'm going to give a little background
around why we're having this talk I'll
get some history of game playing I'm
going to go through some benchmarks for
reinforcement learning
and very briefly describe what
reinforcement learning is I would
encourage you to either look at my
talking three years ago or to look at
some other talks which I'll provide in
the references if you want to go deeper
on that because I'm going to do that
fairly quickly they're not gonna talk
about deep reinforcement learning I'm
going to discuss open AI and some of the
algorithms that they're providing I'm
gonna show that I trained on the game
palm and then I'll provide some
references and feel free to interrupt at
any point okay so the whole point of
this talk is really learning to play
games so and the reason we're talking
about this now is a summation earlier is
there's this general concept of
artificial general intelligence and the
basic idea is that we want to be able to
train things on systems and just have
them learn fully from the environment
without any pre programming at all so
and not only that we also want these
things to be able to these agents to be
able to go from one environment and take
what they learned there and apply it
somewhere else
so the point of general intelligence is
really just that you're learning things
in environments and that you're not
confined to those environments you can
you can apply it of learning elsewhere
human beings obviously do that naturally
but most reinforcement learning problems
historically have had huge problems
you're taking what they learn and
transferring it so I'm going to review
some models and some tools from a deep
mind and opening eyes which are two
organizations that have just been a
complete boon for this industry in no
small part because almost everything
they're doing they're open sourced and
that's just been a profound change and
how things have been done just as a
little bit of background on this when
you think about what progress has been
made in in AI and some of the models I'm
going to discuss in some sense there's
nothing new in what however the show so
there has been a lot of progress in the
last three years but if you look at all
of these models
walk through most of them were developed
in the 80s 90s even before and really
what we're looking at are you know
what's new well we've got a lot more
computing power and that's a non-trivial
difference so we can solve problems now
purely just the computing so for
instance recently Limit poker was solved
by waiver from Alberta and they
literally just computed it I mean it
wasn't anything super fancy going on
when they when they saw the limit for
myself no living poker they did they
have to do something more interesting
but and in that first case they were
able to just purely solve the game just
by computing another big innovation has
been in data and I'm gonna walk through
what I mean by that but you know when we
think about deep learning a big part of
what's been making progress there are
just benchmarks that we have with
competitions lots of data sets for
people to work with and the same thing
now is happening in reinforcement
learning just that there's a lot more
data that people can work with that
didn't exist before
algorithms are definitely important so
again I'm gonna talk about some models
that have been applied recently they're
kind of state of the art in many cases
they're really just taking models that
existed before combining in the
different ways and then lastly you know
just purely infrastructure and I know
non-trivial part of that is just the
code so again some of the things like
markets are in terms of open I that
didn't exist a few years ago it makes
this kind of research so much easier to
do and it really opens up the community
of people working on these problems so
those are all kind of things that may
not be obvious at first but they're
significant to the advances that have
been made so as I mentioned these are
the things that I'm going to be
highlighting I'm using tonight open AI
has two applications that are kind of
the backbone of what they talked about
one it's called Jim and I'll show you
how to use it and I'm also going to be
talking about deep reinforcement
learning so for the deep models we're
going to be using tensorflow there are
other choices you could have made there
about
that's the one I'm choosing and then in
terms of the specific models these are
three of the kind of cutting edge models
so dqn was a model develop aidid minor
and it was the one that they really
became famous for first because they
applied that model to play the entire
atari universe of games with the same
model and that got a lot of attention at
first at this point that's no longer
kind of considered cutting-edge so these
two other models I'm going to talk about
or consider much more efficient why are
we talking about games well I'm gonna
walk through some history of games but
games have for a very long time been
considered kind of the primary
playground for artificial intelligence
well back in time and there are good
reasons for that I mean they really kind
of model the world as we see it so if
we're trying to think about how humans
think in many cases games are kind of
nice little toy examples of how that
works so we can have very large state
spaces meaning there are many different
things that can happen we we also have
this concept of having a reward that
we're trying again and we have to have a
sequence of events to get to it so you
have to do some kind of planning we
could also have adversarial opponents in
games so it's not just a matter of you
finding the best thing to do but you
have to think about what your opponent
might be doing I think we have
uncertainty in states meaning you don't
know exactly what state you're in the
environment may not be clear enough to
you so these are all really important
concepts when it comes to reinforcement
learning as they get a fight in many
areas but games are kind of a really
nice
for example for that and I mean the
other reason is that games are awesome
and fun to play so they're they're good
in that sense too
okay so just a very brief history of
that game many of you I'm sure will be
familiar with Claude Shannon he used her
of information theory and he also is
really famous for having done a lot of
work in games so you know if we go
pretty far back 1950 I wrote this paper
about playing chess and they introduced
quite a few important ideas in that
paper one of which is called mini man
minimax and then that we're basically
trying to minimize our maximum loss as
we're claiming that's an opponent so
I'll just kind of skip around a little
bit down so he was thinking about chess
and you know when you think about the
game of chess one thing you need is you
need to be able to evaluate what the
value of a board position is at a point
in time so that was one thing that he
did he came up with this concept of what
he's looking at a chess board just
saying how valuable is this chess
position but then the next kind of thing
you might say is I'm sitting in a
specific position with all these chess
pieces why can't I just play through
every possible game from now until the
end and see you know given all these
possible rights I could take which is
the best one and make it turns out that
search problem is very hard to do so
even with deep blue which started which
kind of solved the game in 1997 it
didn't just do a pure search there were
lots of tricks involved and I'll touch
on that in a second but this first
innovation was really just to say if I
look forward in time
a few moves which move would maximize or
would minimize my maximum loss that was
this minimax algorithm that the Claude
Shannon introduced it was very important
in 1956 Arthur Samuel created a program
that actually brand IBM computer and at
the time this just got a huge amount of
press so many of you have taken either
machine learning or artificial
intelligence classes may have heard
about this at the time you know this was
kind of viewed as checkers is has been
solved there were a couple of things
about that one is a in no way was it
solved at that point and I don't you
know it's kind of an interesting result
because it got a lot of publicity but
natural effect he played against not a
very good player when you actually look
at the game that he won his opponent
they just horrendously pad move toward
the end so you know in no way he
actually saw the problem but it but to
this day when people talk about checkers
they mostly say you know Arthur Sam
you'll solve that problem back in 1956
it actually took a lot here to solve it
I know you know that also kind of leads
to this other question you know even
taking something like chess when
deep-blue you know one one that famous
game in May 1997 it hasn't solved chess
didn't know what the perfect play was so
really in many of these instances like
for instance go is another good example
of this we're talking about solving a
game it isn't actually solved it's more
a matter of we're better than any human
being and so that's good this kind of
concept of having a superhuman ability
and almost all the things I got to walk
through we haven't solved these things
so it's not a matter of kind of knowing
the optimal players in general it's just
a matter of them we beaten every single
human and that's kind of what we
consider to be having beaten it I talked
about this example when we talked about
reinforcement learning so let's quickly
touch on it again
you know I've mentioned that many of
these ideas are new so a lot of the work
that one NCO for instance went go and
the work that went out of beating Atari
games doesn't have been very famous in
1995 traceur Oh from IBM had I created a
game that beat some of the best
backgammon players in the world and if
you look at the actual model he was
using it was a deep reinforcement
learning model so again this is back in
1995 and it was using a lot of the same
techniques we're talking about now
obviously the most famous kind of recent
cases is go and you know one of the most
challenging things about go is that the
number of states that you can possibly
have and go it's just so large and
that's why I researchers have always
thought go is a problem that would take
years to solve and you know particularly
the number of positions is greater the
number of atoms in the universe okay we
have no hope whatsoever of solving this
game so and when you look at what human
players do they're usually have a
difficult time kind of explaining
exactly why they're making certain moves
so one of the big things about go is
that it it was able to come across
things that we kind of consider to be
intuition
so when I talked about this a few years
ago again this is maybe where I got
criticized a little bit I was talking
about this problem just that there are
these so many states and we know when
you looked at these things and go is a
very widely studied problem at the time
this was considered a very difficult
thing to get around and I mentioned at
the time some of these gradient descent
methods which had been innovating and
you know if we look at how go programs
have been doing up until early
two-thousands their performance a kind
of plateaued and then people started
changing out what they were doing and
they started using these sample based
methods and performance started to
increase again and so you know even back
in 2008 we started to see programs
they're able to be go players that were
considered kind of master level that
being said even though we kind of had
this trajectory go
alphago still was a big innovation so
how'd it go alphago work well it
combined a lot of different things
together and that's one of the things
again that we're gonna see in all of the
kind of cutting-edge state-of-the-art
reinforcement learning models they're
not just simply applying reinforcement
learning they're usually applying
reinforcement learning with some other
aspects to it so in this example the
first thing that they did in alphago was
they took lots of best players gangs
from a very large data set of human
expert games so they did something
that's known as imitation learning so
you look at what humans have done and
then you train your initial network
based on those games then they did
something else which actually was WOW
what Arthur Samuel did when he was
playing checkers which is to say that
they played against themselves over and
over and over again and as they were
doing that what they were making
incremental
provements in their in their network and
so as time went on through self way they
were able to get better and better and
better and by the time they actually
beat least at all they the performance
of the system was so much better than it
had been when they beat the first player
so you know and they can track this so
they could for instance you know every
week they could play against themselves
and they could see how much better they
were getting overtime and just purely
through self play playing against itself
over and over and over again it got
better I was a big contributor to its
success we've also seen again and poker
a lot of breakthroughs and then the last
one I'm just gonna touch on because I
got a lot of attention recently was this
multiplayer game called dota and opening
I got a lot of press you know I must
because all over the place talking about
this as the end of the world it was
coming since then I think people are
kind of step back a little bit and
decide at the end of the world it hasn't
quite a right together but one thing
about this when the solution to dota is
that again one of the main components to
what they were doing was self play they
were playing against themselves
repeatedly in that was
okay so briefly let me just touch on
some benchmarks so you know we've had
deep reinforcement learning discussions
over I have before I'm actually
borrowing some somewhat from them John
Collins talking and this so I should
make sure that you go and look at his
talk if you've got any questions on what
I'm going through
but one you know for me one of the kind
of underappreciated things that causes
major innovation when it comes to
machine learning and artificial
intelligence it's just the availability
of data and competitions also so you
know having every year these
competitions with available data that
everyone going to use has led to just
this massive boon within the industry so
and this was one of the first and a
major datasets that people started
focusing on for deep reinforcement
learning and it was just a matter of
classifying lots of handwritten digits
and anytime you know you go and look at
a deep deeper enforcement learning model
you can almost always this is the first
problem you go that's all so you know if
you open up the tensorflow hopefully
step one vote so again it's just really
valuable and as time went on you also
see innovation and kind of datasets so
you know I've included by the way you
know this talk will be available
afterwards so I'll feel like you have to
take any notes or anything well I have
lots of links to things so you know if
you want more detail you'll you'll see
it there but in Internet again was a
very big data set at this point has
effectively been solved and if you know
if you just see the growth in time of
missus classification or how that it's
improved over time at this point models
have just gotten to the point where
it's almost perfect and so that that
time okay you know we have this
incredible image that data set to work
with lots of people were learning from
it the point we're kind of telling on
that so we're gonna need a new data set
this is kind of how things have evolved
so when I spoke a few years ago I talked
about a particular reinforcement
learning toolkit that people were using
but at this point open AI has something
called gym so I kind of demonstrate and
it was totally my opinion revolutionize
how people can deal with these problems
so from opening I it's it's a trivial
matter of launching kind of classical
control problems like for instance with
robots I'll give an example of something
called the car the portal problem which
again is just a classic reinforcement
learning problem where you've got a cart
and you're just trying to figure out how
how can you can move this cart to keep a
pole balanced also there are board games
including go so you can actually go in a
opening I and start trying to let go
there's the entire Atari 2600 platform
the Joko is a thing this kind of physics
simulator so if you can simulate a human
being
walk you can go there and again this is
very popular with robotics researchers
so that you know these are things that
are actually being used not only in
industry but in academia as well widely
to solve these kinds of robotics
problems and we also see you know my
minecraft doing lots of very popular
games even that exist now like for
instance
that I was mentioning earlier is getting
made available lastly I just mentioned
Robo school is another tool that was
released by open air recently and one
thing about kind of the original gym
platform that's not ideal from how you
know how a lot of these models are fit
is that it's limited to a single player
playing against the computer what you'd
actually like to be doing it's a lot of
self play in many cases so Robo school
allows for multiple agents so you have a
multiple agent problem okay so let's
just talk very briefly about
reinforcement learning okay so this is a
model of reinforcement learning we have
in an agent and you can specify that
agent however you want but we've got
this cycle there's an agent there's an
environment and then the agent is gonna
take actions the environment is I'm
gonna tell the Asia a new state and
reward so we're going through this cycle
over and over and over again where it's
gonna be interacting with the
environment receiving a state on reward
so if we just try to formalize this a
little bit and uh I'm gonna keep the
math I really do a minimum but I just
want to give a little formalism so again
what we're doing is we're inserting the
states taking actions receiving awards
transitioning into other states and you
know we're gonna represent States by s
actions by a and the rewards we're gonna
represent by our I mentioned this in my
last talk but these these symbols I'm
using here are common to reinforcement
learning literature the other place
where these exact same model has popped
up was in operations research now if you
look there are these different symbols I
think they use au for actions and an
expert states
maybe someone correct you can correct me
on that but in any case the symbols are
different which
you know just kind of an unfortunate
state of affairs but if you look at
those two literature's they basically
come up with the exact same thing and
they use different apologies and the
reinforcement learning literature by the
way which is I think at this point very
mature kind of lag behind operations
research for a long time so a lot of the
kinds of problems I'm talking about like
robotics for instance were being solved
pretty effectively by methods and
operations research for a pretty long
time too but they weren't using the same
approach as we're using here which is to
say they're mostly not having this kind
of like neural network or or a model
driven approach for the most part what
they were doing was they would take
States and they would model the States
really effectively so they would put a
lot of work into coming up with
basically future engineering trying to
make those features really informative
and useful and then running a model well
we're doing is a little different we're
not trying to put any structure in the
problem to relate reinforcement learning
to problems that so you may already be
familiar with many of you will be
familiar with Markov chains so the most
common reinforcement learning problem is
called a Markov decision process and a
Markov decision process MVP is different
from a Markov chain
it just said you have these control over
transitions let me just walk through
what that model looks like
so Markov chains are very
straightforward we just have one state
we're transition to the next state and
the key point about the Markus game is
that it has this thing called the Markov
property which is just to say that the
probability of being in a certain state
of an extra miracle is not dependent on
the full history of states it's only
dependent on the immediate prior state
that's known as a Markov property we're
gonna make use of that here but but the
key point is just that when you go from
one state to the next to the next
there's no relationship you don't need
to know and you know state three here
did you want to save one before all you
need to know is here in state two so a
Markov decision process adds a little
bit to this we still have this
transitions between states and you still
have this Markov property so we only not
need to know what the previous state was
we don't need to know multiple states
back but what are we adding we're having
the fact that we're not only in a state
but we're in the state and we're going
to take an action and given that action
we're going to receive a reward and then
we're going to transition so there's
this flow to it we've got these extra
components the other thing I would just
mention and for the sake of my talk it's
not very important but some of you will
be familiar with hidden Markov models
and those models you don't know the
state you only get some kind of noisy
estimate of the state close observation
now and we have an analogue and
reinforcement warning called the
partially observable Markov decision
process this was important when we're
modeling for instance poker where you
don't know what the other hands are you
kind of assume some concept of what
people might be holding so in that case
again rather than knowing what the state
is we just have an observation of the
state but everything else remains the
same okay so here's the main piece of
math again I'll try to move through this
quickly so we can get on to actual life
of applications but what are we trying
to solve in a reinforcement learning
problem what we're trying to do is is
maximize return so again we're taking
actions and it Givens in a given state
to move into another state and over time
what we want to do is maximize our
return again if you're in operations
research you talk about minimizing loss
instead of maximizing return it's just a
slate it's literally just you take the
negative of loss and get toward the
positive return but you know we're a
little more optimistic and reinforcement
learning so wow we have this concept of
a value function and again many of you
may have seen dynamic programming before
that's all we're talking about here so
we have a value function and that value
function basically says given a certain
state what's the value of a in this
state so again you could think about
that chessboard there all these pieces
on
or given that I have these pieces in
this board what's the value to me what's
my chance of winning the game and we
have this term here which I'll talk
about more in a minute pi and that
represents what's known as a policy so
the policy just says I'm in this state s
and then I'm gonna take a sequence of
actions until the game is finished
so you could just think about can I go
completely rolling out the rest of the
game from from where I am now until the
end what's the value of this thing
what's the value this thing it's a
reward I receive right now bless the
reward I receive the next state I go
with them to let's the reward I go in
through the state after that and so
forth until the end and again we're
talking about this for a specific set of
state transitions and then we're adding
a one other term here which is a
discount factor and that helps
convergence in these problems in many
cases without that discount factor it'll
never converge and you know another
aspect of this
these are optimization problems and they
can be over very very noisy kind of
surfaces so one big problem that people
run into is you can often depending upon
how you do these problems you can end up
in kind of local minimum or local
maximum you're depending upon how you
define it so you this discount factor is
crucial and one of the innovations again
the least how we can solve these
problems is just redefining this value
function in terms of this thing called
the bellman equation and it's really
just the same thing we're just saying
what's the reward for a given state
assuming we had follow a certain policy
and we're sorry what's the value given
the reward I received right now plus all
the future rewards and this t term
basically says what's the probability of
going from one state to the next this so
this again would just tell you exactly
what the value of being in this position
is this Q function which when I thought
and talked about DQ DQ networks well
coming important so Q is
just the exact same thing as V with one
addition to it so we're a bit saying not
only am I going to follow this policy to
the end but I'm following this policy
from the state right now I'm taking a
specific action hey so that way you know
if I'm in a state now I could take
however many different actions if I'm in
chest for instance I could move one
column I could move some other piece and
it'll just tell me what's the value of
taking that one action and then
following the policy of till the end so
the only difference in these equations
is really just that this is specific to
taking immediate action otherwise the
equation is the same then the only other
term I'm just gonna find is called an
advantage function so the advantage
function basically says okay Q is the
value for being in a state of taking a
certain action V is the value for being
that state and following the policy
together so what's the difference
between being in a state of taking a
certain action versus being a statement
following a policy so that's known as
the advantage function and we're gonna
use that in one of these models and the
basic idea is if a certain action in a
certain state adds more value than
another one then I want to kind of lean
more in that direction so I'm gonna give
more weight to those certain actions and
what what are we trying to learn from
this whole thing so the objective of
reinforcement learning is to maximize
value or return but that's given a
certain at the end we're gonna result in
a policy and the policy you can just
think of this like a table an in a state
I should take a certain action now
there's another way of defining this as
what's the optimal policy so you can
think again let's say you know I'm
walking across the room what's the
shortest path well you know I could go
around this way I keep around that way
and so forth those are all policies one
of them is going to be optimal and that
we're gonna try to fight it at the end
and you know at the end again we could
just simply have a table that would say
given a certain state take a certain
action if the environment is much more
complex like we're gonna see then we
would not use a table because a table
isn't sufficiently dynamic to be able to
describe things so you know in the
version of reinforcement learning we
talked about three years ago I was
mostly focused on this kind of table
approach that means that the states have
to be very limited you can add very many
states so for instance in robot control
people talk about continuous control how
could you have continuous states if
states are continuous if we can move
anywhere in the world then I can't
define that in a discreet way and I
can't use the table so then we need to
use a model that's where we're gonna use
a a deep reinforcement or where we're
gonna use deep learning it's basically
just to replace this table and it allows
us to get continuous views on the world
okay so going from that simple model of
having a table where we say I'm gonna
stay then I'm gonna take an action now
we want to do something called function
approximation so instead of having a
table we're gonna have a function and
there are different ways of doing these
things we can have either value-based
ones in that case what we're gonna do is
we're gonna say these are all the states
of the world each state has a certain
value and in alphago they were able to
come up with a value function that was
one of the big innovations of what they
did they will look at the board and
again the board is far too complex for
them to know every possible state but
they were able to come up with a
function that gave them a value when
they looked at that state so it's some
kind of no easy estimate of what the
value was and one thing you can do is if
you know what the value of every
possible state is if you want to know
what actions to take and you just simply
try to look at all the values and
maximize them right so that's what we do
in a values-based model we we learn a
value function and then we use something
like epsilon greedy where basically we
just randomly sample I try to choose the
actions to maximize to get a policy the
other thing to do would be say I don't
care about the value all I care about is
what I should do right so in that case
all I'm trying to do is get to this
function that says given a state take an
action
you don't care if you're getting you
know value of 10 or value of thousand
all you care is that it's the best thing
to do so that's not as a policy based
approach and in that case we don't we
don't learn the value function we just
learn the policy and that's part of the
model that a lot of of the most recent
the reinforcement learning model is
invested on and then the last one that
all that your honor
it's called actor critic and in that one
we learned both the value function and
the policy again there's more work
involved in this so it runs more slowly
in some sense but by learning both we're
able to get a benefit out of it okay so
I'm just gonna very quickly touch on how
are we doing policy search so again the
whole point is what we want to know is
what set of actions should I take I
don't care what the value is I just want
to know what to do and there are
different methods of doing this and
again these are to really just question
is kind of how we gonna optimize this
function but but basically what we're
going to end up doing is
taking a gradient of a loss function so
again if you're familiar with
optimization this is gonna be a very
simple familiar routine so we've got
this tournament here that we're trying
to get an expectation of and what this
tournament I'm just going to define very
quickly it's called the scorer function
and in here we're taking the gradient of
the policy so there's a policy changing
and then we're multiplying it by the
value so what this function is gonna end
up doing is we optimize it it's to say
given a certain value I want to give
more weight to things to changes in
gradients that are again giving me more
value so if it's more valuable to do it
this way I'm going to increase the
weight on that and we're gonna do that
using this gradient descent method
okay so what's deep reinforcement
learning in this case the state stasis
weights at large we can get the table
based method so again I'm gonna presume
that most of you went to the deeper end
where are the deep learning I'll talk
about the floor but you know we're gonna
use neural networks unless these models
don't have to by the way you can use a
linear regression you could use a
Gaussian process you can use lots of
different things some people do it
happens that neural networks at this
point are probably the most popular we
could talk about why but in a neural
network its have lots of nodes and
they're gonna be getting applied weights
and then we're gonna determine the
output based on some kind of activation
function and you know in a deep model
we're gonna have many many different
layers when John gave his talk he
included this slide in there I think
it's just kind of an important point to
make that you know one of the big
innovations in deep learning
particularly with image classification
is not only that these networks are
becoming more structured so that's
important like for instance now we have
convolution
works which I'll show you in a second
but also they've become deeper and
deeper and deeper and by becoming deeper
models were able to learn more complex
structures you know this is just two
pictures of deep neural network models
and and just one point I just wanted to
make about this which is that when you
look at a lot of deep learning models
now for instance convolution networks
what they're often trying to do is look
at something where again you could
imagine like the state space is too
large you're looking at all these
pictures lots of pixels but we want to
look at those all those pixels and then
generalize well we want to say you know
this picture contains a cab and this
other picture contains a cab right even
though there might be lots of other
things the picture might be lots of
things going on so how do they go about
doing that well first of all they use
these convolution networks where they
kind of manipulate the image and look at
parts of it at a time that way they're
able to get regions and they're able to
get edges of things and so forth another
thing they do which we are not going to
do at all as known as pooling and one of
the concepts behind pooling is that
Biscay where the cat is in the picture
is irrelevant all right all I want to
know in a lot of these in the image
classification problems is there was a
cat right so this these edges that I've
learned in that in this image represent
a cat and it doesn't matter that it was
sitting on a couch or on the woods but
in our problem we do care about that we
carry about position we care about
momentum all these kinds of things so
we're not going to do any poor in any of
the
reinforcement learning models I'm gonna
use tensorflow I'm not gonna go through
a lot of detail how to use it but you
know with a lot of these libraries that
are available now you can for instance
create a convolution Network in one line
right so just you know going back to my
comment earlier a lot of these libraries
that exist now have really increased
innovation of these things because it's
created these out-of-the-box things that
we can use very quickly okay so the
first model I'm gonna talk about is
called deep Q networks so we looked at
that Q function and effectively you know
in a Q learning model we're gonna take
that Q function and we're gonna use a
bell and then back up right so we're
just gonna try to really learn that
value function and given the value
function we're then gonna learn what a
policy is one innovation that deepmind
introduced into this was that not only
did they do this to a cute network
actually I had a picture of it so um
what a couple of things one is first of
all that they did convolution neural
network so you know they didn't for
instance have some model of the
environment to begin with they just
simply had pixels that they were looking
at okay so when you're thinking about
image recognition and so forth they took
the same kind of model and they did
convolution they didn't do pooling as I
mentioned before and then once they've
gone through convolution to kind of try
to reduce the state space of the image
then they had some fully connected
layers and that was where they were
learning basically you can see what they
were sitting on was the action that take
so you can think of it this way through
as they're going through this deep
neural network the first stage is
they're just simplifying the image to
try to come up with a smaller state
space and then the later stages they're
meant fitting what action to take
action gave the most reward and in a
minute I'm going to actually run a DQ I
model and they can talk about a little
more detail the next model I just want
to talk about is known as a three seed
and this is an actor critic method so I
would mention actor critic before in
that case we learned both the value
function and we learn the policy and by
doing both together we're able to
actually you know we're actually able to
do things more quickly it takes up more
RAM and so forth but it's able to move
to more quickly than a queue learning
well so let me just quickly distinguish
policy Viridian I'm actor critic so I
mentioned earlier policy gradient and I
had this score function and the
advantage actor critic model which is
what we're doing in a three C and a 3 C
by the way stands for asynchronous
advantage actor critic oh but I'll show
you what's different about that versus
advantage if you're really in a second
but here again we're we're just taking
the gradient of this last function and
really what we're doing is in this case
this value function has been replaced by
the advantage function so I mentioned
earlier what the advantage function is
it's just the difference between a cue
function which is the value for being in
a state of taking an action and the
value so what this ends up doing is
basically saying you know this policy
improves my value by a small amount
so we're modeling not only the the
policy but also the advantage and this
is what the asynchronous part of this
additive so an A 3 C which I'll show you
I ran this and it does quite quite well
it has multiple instances of the event
critic running in parallel and then it
has one global network and it takes each
of the results from the independent ones
and it updates the global value you know
again within this thing we've got a
neural network for the policy and for
the value function so we're learning
both more quickly I'm the last one I'm
just gonna mention because this is kind
of at this point from the deep mind set
point by the way all these models are
from deep mind and not only you know are
they publishing the papers but a lot of
the source code that they used in the
paper is also on their web site which
I'd link to in neural episodic control
the big innovation that they're tackling
there is if you look at DQ n the number
of instances that we have to run through
is very very large so I I think they
basically ran these models to play as
hard games for 38 days straight and when
you think about it human beings we don't
need that many interactions so this is
kind of one of the big problems that
reinforcement learning researchers are
focusing on right now how is it the
human beings can play a game like pong
and instantly know what to do you know
you can learn after one single play what
to do but we have to play for 38 days
even with you know a pretty
sophisticated deep reinforcement
learning so neural episode of control is
using some some very cool research about
how the brain functions to learn from
single instances so what this does is it
keeps a memory of every sink or low it
keeps a memory of as many states and
actions as it can keep in memory and you
know if that memory overflows and it
simply gets rid of the oldest ones and
so what it does is you know if we again
after you think about pong you know if
you saw the ball moving a certain way
and a certain thing happened you would
just look out what was the thing that
happened last time that did that happen
that's supposed to kind of generalizing
what's happening like
when the ball is moving a certain way
you say specifically in this instance
when the ball moved that way what
happened and so by kind of recording
some limited memory it's able to learn
from single instances and so you know
again when we look at how things have
evolved this is substantially faster
than in the earlier model okay so how
come we have to run these things
so this is where open egg the eye comes
in an egg release a number of tools what
I'm gonna focus on is called GM the
universe is kind of an extension there
Jim it allows you to do lots of more
environments including things that are
run you know even through the web so you
could have some environment that's on
website and you could run it through
universe so it's a very flexible
environment for being able to add things
Robo school is something every looks
recently and allows multiple agents in
Iraq and then baselines is something I'm
also going to touch on which i think is
just awesome
and so in baselines not only have they
taken you know that's how all the Atari
games and made them available to us but
now they've also taken all of the
cutting-edge models and they're making
them available too so so if you know if
you want to dig into this further I
strongly encourage you to go look look
there so you know the models I was
discussing earlier some of them are
gonna basics right now and you can go in
and look at them and they're very nice
implementations so you know in terms of
kind of making reinforcement learning
kind of out of the box they're going a
long way toward then so how does an AI
work it's very straightforward so the
first thing is you've got some kind of
environment that has to be predefined
maybe that's the hardest part of this
whole thing I mean if you want to apply
this in your own work you need to define
an environment and that frankly is where
a lot of the challenge comes in but if
if you're on a study a model then you
can use any out-of-the-box environment
you can play an Atari game you can
you know use a robot whatever it is if
you can work on those models so I'm not
gonna go into too much detail around how
to make an environment even though even
the interface for making environment is
it's pretty simple but but actually a
plane's problems in your case could be
difficult and again maybe you know later
on over beers we could talk about how
you do that but that's a great topic for
you know over beers so the first thing
you do is you make your environment and
by the way this is Python for anyone
who's not oh no you're a Python there is
a which I'll show in a minute there's
also our code and julia code for this
and the next thing i'm gonna do is i'm
repping a monitor around this and so
this is gonna save the results of the
model that I'm running so another thing
that Jim does which is just awesome is
that you can take the model that you run
here save the results are in and then
you can upload it to their environment
and so they'd create a not only and
infrastructure for people to create
environments and test models but they've
also create an infrastructure for you to
be able to compare yourself against
everyone else so it's really opened up
and how we can compare things and learn
then we're gonna iterate so you didn't
rate until your environment tells you
you're done basically so the environment
is gonna if you call this function it's
gonna render I'll show you what that
means in a second then we're gonna take
an action from the state space so you
know for instance if you're playing pong
you can either stay still you can go up
or you can look down those are the three
actions and your environment maybe
you're gonna click on a mouse I mean
whatever actions you could possibly take
then we're gonna take a step in the
environment given that action and open
AI is going to return the next
stay again in this case we're referring
to it as an observation because when
we're talking about Atari for instance
mostly excuse me were thinking about
observations because we're not clear
about what state were in because the
state space is so large so really we're
approximating what the state space is
through this neural network so it's
going to return what the next state is
it's going to return a reward for taking
that action and it's going to tell you
if you're finished those are the three
main things so and in the case of pong
for instance being finished means that
either you won or lost the game and in
pong you play up until 21 so once one of
the players reaches 21 this would be
returned it's done and then you could
reset the environment and go again okay
so you can keep on going until maybe
this converges in some way no the part
that down
that's really abstracted away in this
simple example is is this line here
right in this case I'm just taking an
action randomly what you're gonna want
to do is plug in your model in this case
and those were the models that I was
referring to earlier like a three C for
instance then once we're done we're
gonna close the environment and if you
want to you can upload it into open air
so other people can see your results and
you can compare yourself to other people
as well so that's the whole thing right
it's very simple very concise the main
thing that we have to worry about is
what's happening here where we're
choosing actions I mentioned baselines
earlier I'm gonna give an example of how
that works in a second but in baselines
they've implemented a few of the cutting
edge models including TQM and also on
baselines I don't know how to zoom but
I'll just tell you what what this shows
so in this picture there are lots of
different
Atari game sir each one of these boxes
represents a specific Atari game so you
know again Wow
if you look at any of the deepmind
papers about these new models in order
for them to decide that a new model is
better than an old model they have to be
able to learn all of the Atari games
better I mean you may want to learn it
more quickly that might be a challenge
you may want to get better scores and
more games that might be a challenge
there are some games that some models
just can't play at all for instance and
then it's important to know okay what
was it about this game that meant that
this model couldn't learn it right but
you can't really make it out here but
the I think it's the dark blue line is
is once one of them like newest models
so it's it's even beyond ac3 and that's
I've performed these other ones by quite
a bit so actually in these pictures this
red line is a c3 a c3 which is an actor
critic model that I was talking about
before was already significantly better
than dqn which was again the models in
2013 where deep mine I played all these
Atari games got a lot of attention for
it so these other newer models are
already significantly better than AC 383
see the other thing I just mentioned but
I'm not gonna go on a detail on there
are other alternatives to reinforcement
learning and opening AI is also looking
at this but one you know that's been
known again just for a long time it's
evolutionary strategies so they wrote a
nice paper and again their source code
did you can look at to see how this
works but in this case we're not going
through this whole reinforcement
learning problem we're just literally
sampling different strategies and then
each iteration we're just going to take
the strategies that work the best we're
going to go to
we're going to sample again and we're
kind of kind of evolved in that way so
let me just very quickly well so I I was
hoping to show you what what the
training one of these models looks like
so this is a baseline model and we're
gonna learn cart pull and you know just
well I'm talking there you go I kick it
off by the way does someone know how to
zoom on a Mac nobody what's that Oh No
yeah okay so what's happening here is
we're running on a specific problem I
call a cart pole problem and I'm gonna
show you what that problem looks like in
a second but when this thing starts off
it knows nothing about this problem so
we've got a card and the card can move
from side to side that's why do you have
control over and you're trying to
balance a pole so you can imagine when
this thing starts up you know
immediately the pole falls over and we
it kind of keeps trying to do that over
and over again and eventually it gets
the point where the pole is stable and
this is going to complete in a second I
mean it you know it's kind of amazing to
me how quickly this runs and this
computer by the way is terrible it's
very very old so you know if you have
access to Facebook's Network or
something this would be done yesterday
probably but what I'm running here right
now is we're doing this card pole
problem we're stepping through all those
episodes like I was just showing in that
open
Berman and sorry
and after each instance we're this is
doing TQM so it's got that Q Network
which represents the policy and the
value and and we're gonna be fitting
that model based on again in this case
we're just looking at pixels we can't
see the pixels yet but in a minute I'll
bring it up okay now while that's
running again I'm gonna keep moving and
we'll come back to this I'll show you
how does it learn to balance the spool
okay so let me let me try to wrap up to
be quickly here okay so the last thing
I'm just gonna walk through is I'm gonna
literally step through plank pong and
I'm gonna do it using a model for Aundre
car Kathy who's now the head of a Tesla
but for a long time was teaching AI
at Stanford and you know I'm not gonna
walk through every line of code but but
this is literally I think 120 characters
or sorry 120 lines maybe a Python and it
doesn't use basically any external
libraries except you so we're gonna do a
deep reinforcement learning model from
scratch and we're going to learn tom now
and then I'm gonna show you the
difference between that model which is
pretty cool to a three-c which I which I
ran you know which is a little more
involved just in terms of how well it
performed okay so pong you're familiar
with them you know if you play ping pong
exact same rules we've got two paddles
one can move up or down
we're playing us the computer in this
case and you get a point every time the
ball exits the screen so you know we're
gonna be on this side and our opponent
is gonna be over here and once we get
the 21 the game is over so we're gonna
play the game over and over and over
again right I think in the and the DQ
and the one day they played maybe 200
million games or something like that so
you know a lot more than human being
with people
to do obviously now what's the structure
so again just coming back to
reinforcement learning we're gonna get a
reward every time we win a game a
plus-one and every time we lose again
we're gonna get the -1 and what we care
about is long-term value so we're gonna
sum up all of those those rewards and if
we get to 21 plus 21 that would mean
we've won -21 we've we lost every single
point and over the long run we want it
we care about how many games are we
winning right
the actions are up or down in this
example the states are the full set of
pixels okay but in this case we're not
going to use convolution neural network
so it's just a very simple network but
we are going to manipulate the image a
little bit to simplify it so I'll show
you that and then yeah so that's exactly
right so we're gonna take that full set
of pixels and we're gonna reduce it down
just to be 80 by 80 and we're gonna feed
that in our network and this is the bet
you know like a picture basically what
we're doing we're taking these raw
pixels we're gonna feed them into a
neural network in this case we're gonna
have two layers of two of 200 nodes each
and the outcome of that is going to be
what's the probability we should move up
that's what we're fitting on so every
time we play a game we play the whole
way through and then we're gonna be
learning you know the fact that I did
all of these little moves you know give
in certain states I moved up or down and
that'll led to a reward or not so it's
it again if you think about this problem
it's really kind of incredible that it
works right we're looking at these
pictures we're feeding them into a
neural network and then after you know
making thousands of moves random
randomly I'm gonna be able to assign
back the fact that I moved up you know a
minute ago
will happen to be valuable but not could
it that could happen a long time ago
over many actions so it's kind of
incredible to me that this works the
other thing it's kind of hard to see
this this is just kind of looking at
what the weights are inside the neural
network and in this case you know I'm
taking this directly from I'm very
pretty but you know would be easy enough
to recreate this you've got this model
of these nodes and you're just saying
what are the weights and you know when
you think of these nodes it's
representing this 80 by 80 matrix of
things so if it's white that means it
was activated or not and Biscay what
this is gonna do is it's gonna say if
you look at this it's kind of hard to
look at but know you'll see some shapes
they're kind of evident right it's it's
all so noisy that we use the convolution
neural network or something it would
have been clearer but you'll see like
for instance Lyons right this means that
if the ball was in any of these places
that this node and this neural network
would have fired right which would have
kind of cascaded and said okay I should
move up or down whatever it is so that's
kind of what's going on within the
neural network you're modeling this
entire state space just using this
neural network finish all right so so
this is what the card poll result ends
up looking like so again you know if I
showed you this picture at the very
beginning literally just been you know
this pole which is this rod and again
when this thing is learning this model
it's just literally doing what we're
done it's looking at this picture right
and it takes us you can think of it this
way it takes a screenshot of that
picture and then it moves but it might
move to the right or to the left and you
know within the time that we were
here it completely mastered this problem
of being able to just simply balance
this bowl that's a very simple example
but every single time now I can just
kind of keep dancing that bowl forever
and when it started off with nothing
right at the beginning so it's really
just amazing alright so now let's go
over to
I'm gonna run the pong example and thank
you guys all for bearing with me we'll
wrap this up quickly okay so here's the
code and by the way not only this but a
lot of other examples that I'm not gonna
walk through or up on my github account
and that link will be in the
presentation so you'll be able to find
it okay so this is just slightly adapted
from Andres example so let me quickly
walk through a little bit of this again
if you want to go into detail feel free
to pull the code apart yourself but
you'll see here I'm importing some
functions at the very beginning
the only thing really that's kind of
unusual here in the sense is Jim I'm not
importing tensorflow I'm not using
anything too sophisticated everything
here is just done out of the box here
I'm defining a few different things
related to the gradient descent model so
we're gonna do a stochastic policy
gradient so we talked about that model
earlier basically what we're doing is
we're kind of going through when looking
at a policy of you know moving up down
and so forth and it could be just
completely random to begin with and then
we're gonna be saying as time goes on
we're gonna say okay given that I took a
certain action how much more valuable
was that action than the value that I
already know about and I'm gonna be kind
of incrementally moving my weights in
that direction that's what policy
gradient is doing these functions here
this is just discounted reward function
I showed that earlier in terms of just
summing up the rewards and discounting
them with that with that function here
we're gonna be moving forward through
the neural network and by the way the
neural network is is here I mean it's
literally just a dictionary with some
with some values and we're gonna be
randomly initialize again so we have two
layers of weights but that's all that's
required for this and you know
a sigmoid function for whether neural
network is gonna activate
we're gonna be doing this walking
forward through the network to get an
action so at each state I'm gonna show
you we're gonna be kind of getting what
our current state is we're gonna be
walking through they're all networked to
say what action we should take now give
it on what we know already and then
we're gonna take that action we're gonna
see what happens and then at the end
we're gonna do this backward iteration
to try to update the weights within the
internal network and that's what this
next function is doing it's it's doing a
back pass through the neural network
okay so this should be familiar here
we're initializing the pong environment
again you know you could have thought of
any Atari game what do then here the
only change I would have had to make for
this is well first of all you know two
layers with 200 no it's may not have
been the right model for another game it
may have been insufficient to learn some
games it happens to work in pom which is
a pretty simple game but you know if I
had just changed this to be another
Atari game okay I can't think of one off
that man just literally right this right
here okay and so then I'm gonna render
the environment I'm going to pre-process
the observations all that's knowing is
instead of again using convolution
neural networks I'm just going to take
those pixels and I'm gonna reshape them
so they're kind of long so I could feed
them into the network and I'm gonna make
it I'm gonna cut off excess information
so I'm going to create an 80 by 80 grid
of that pong screen so I'm just getting
rid of extra pixels that I don't need
then I'm gonna go forward through the
network that I already have and that's
going to give me this probability of
whether I should move up or down then
I'm gonna move along and I'm going to
take a step in the environment so that
action could either be 2 or 3 ok and my
choice of whether I'm going to move up
or down is partly as part of random
right and and that's part of again
reinforcement learning in depth we need
to be able to explore the environment so
you know that gets into kind of like
epsilon greedy as a selection method but
but basically we need to have some
randomization and there otherwise we're
gonna sit get stuck in local minima or a
local minimum maximum so we're gonna
randomly choose an action based on our
existing knowledge so you know if this
probability is a certain level then
we're more likely to take a certain
action and then we're gonna take a step
and we're gonna get told what the next
state is what the next reward is and
then we're also gonna be told if we're
done and then we're gonna add all that
together and we're gonna propagate it
back through the network and then
finally you know when we're done we're
gonna kind of save this information down
okay so that's the whole thing
so let me just run this very quickly and
you'll just see so this
I can't I can't zoom on this
all right you're gonna have to use your
imagination for those of you in the back
apologies I don't seem to be able to
increase the size of that but let me
just talk briefly about what's happening
here so first of all I trained this
model for three days just running out of
my computer now I'm gonna show you a
different model in a second that I ran
for eight hours in a converge to perfect
play I mean that effectively every time
it gets 21 meaning that it gets every
single point this model which is pretty
simple is I think getting an average
reward after three days of that zero
meaning that you know it's basically
time right sometimes it wins sometimes
it loses but it's it's not dominant in
any way shape or form and it's also kind
of able to play okay right I mean when I
started this again that paddle was just
moving around completely randomly and it
was getting completely destroyed right
it was twenty-one to zero every single
time when I started up this process and
now you know we can actually sit here
and it's kind of like semi entertaining
to watch right because you kind of root
for the green guy you know sometimes he
wins and you know we could we could sit
here watch this all night what we want
now just to quickly wrap this up
so this ran for three days it's very
simple model when I ran the a3 C model I
ran that and within eight hours this
here I'm using tensorflow and it had
converged and it you know what this
shows is from tensorflow
all the cheese I just want to show two
aspects of this very quickly so first of
all when when it started playing at the
very beginning you'll notice this shows
how long it took to play the game
and at the very beginning it took no
time to play and there's a good reason
for that every single time it missed the
ball right so at the very beginning it
was just horrendous ly bad and it took
no time to play and it got minus 20
points so it lost every single game and
within eight hours it was getting the
maximum score basically every single
time and you'll notice another
interesting kind of thing about this
which is initially it took no time to
play because it was horrendous
then it took a fairly long time to play
because it was kind of playing with the
computer relative the equal terms and
then it started to take less time and
that was because it was just dominating
right so you know and again this is a
really bad computer and it was able to
just crush pong within within eight
hours using a safe 3ec algorithm the big
answer over what we have in the past
okay so let me just wrap up and again
I'm really sorry this is taking so long
so the end of this presentation I walk
just through you know some code examples
that are available including you know I
mentioned there's there's our code so
you can get all those gem functions are
available are and they're also available
on Julia and then lastly there's some
great code examples out on the web and
some great courses which I also list
here so so that's all thing so sorry for
running over I don't know if anyone has
any questions they're a couple of
questions yeah
which kind of model isn't oh no it's not
yeah I know it's actually it's actually
just doing gradient policy search so
it's it's not even any of the models
really - I discussed it's a it's a very
simple gradient policy search model
which is literally just basically
searching through all kinds of random
sets of actions and over time just
taking those actions and trying to move
them in the right direction so it's a
similar concept but but it's not
learning a valued function so that's
what's different yeah yeah and I'll
include the link in the talk and maybe
Jerry kind of kind of clued it many
sense around
so that's a great question the question
was basically how do you deal with
problems that have kind of credit credit
assignment problems right where you
might it might take many a so in these
examples the number of actions you have
to take to complete an episode is not
that long I mean it is still kind of off
in the future but and some other games
you know it could take forever so one
way to adjust that problem like for
instance you know marry a Mario Brothers
in space we can solve I mean I don't
know how complex that is compared to
like doing for instance or something
else but one way you can do that is
really just to reduce the scope of the
each episode so maybe rather than trying
to learn enough how Mario can be all of
the levels to the end you just see how
Mario can get through part of it right
you're so in other words you're gonna
have smaller episodes and you're gonna
try to generalize from experience so
anytime you see you know some kind of
shape of an object you're gonna jump
right same thing could be applied to
most of those games I think in the sense
that you know even though it could be a
very long time before you reach a
complete an end state you're really just
trying to generalize what kinds of
things are you doing throughout the
course of play and and you and you could
do that anymore but I'm not really
probably directly answering your
question but but if you look at for
instance that NEC algorithm one thing it
does is it really kind of reduces the
scope of the episodes that ask to look
at so you're really just saying what
happened in this exact case now your
memory constrained which is a big
problem but if you can kind of reduce
the scope of the problems and then maybe
get address
oh yeah yeah yeah I mean it kind of
depends on the algorithm so a three-c is
one that you can parallelize so in that
case it's a great model for putting put
your have the cluster there's another
version of a 3c which is in that
baselines which is called a to see it's
just a very small modification of that
algorithm and it and it's really well
designed for GPUs for instance so you
know all of those things when you can
paralyze they run a lot faster in that
example when I was running that
asynchronous model I had two cores and
it was using both but obviously if I
could have used it a whole grid it would
have taken a lot
well every kind of episode within the
game so an episode in the game is
defined by the game about whether you
know you move one pixel at a time or
whatever it is right yeah although since
it's so late I'll just take one more
question yeah
yeah so you know I mentioned well first
of all you know again with all of these
models if you've got a toy case you know
in baselines you could literally pull
down a real an already fit model so you
know that's great you don't have to
spend the eight days so I I did training
in but I think more kind of generally
speaking you know how can I apply the
knowledge that I learned in pong to play
a different game right that so that's
called transfer learning and that's a
big problem area as well deep mind put
out a paper a little while ago
addressing that I'm basically what they
did was they look through the network of
the game they've already trained on and
they used another neural network to say
what parts of this network are helping
me in my new game and so it tried to
take knowledge from that existing neural
network and to kind of reapply it in the
new setting by using another model to
say which parts help so that's a big
area of research honestly and I don't
think it's even remotely solved the
being able to kind of transfer
information um but I think well you know
last word I'll say almost like more
generally to your point
everything I've showed here is this
completely generic right we're taking
pixels in and we're learning what to do
and that's what's really really cool but
on the other hand we're in the real
world you don't have to do that right I
mean you can program in for information
about the specific problem you're
working on and that's going to improve
what you're doing so if you have some
prior of you know how a certain
environment works or you know physics
information for instance if you put that
information it's going to perform much
better and then in the real world we
have to do that kind of thing all the
time you have to put information that
you know about the
in there if you really wanted to perform
better Debbie said you know this is just
amazing in my opinion that we could just
go from knowing absolutely nothing about
something I just look at some pictures
and learn about it all right so if
anyone has further questions you can
always correspond with me otherwise I
will be wandering out for drinks and I'd
love to catch up then thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]